les habitants d'argenton sur creuse et
des environs ne désarme pas à l'heure du
déjeuner ils se sont retrouvés devant la
gare avec du vin chaud et des slogans
pour réclamer des trains le matin et le
soir au départ et à l'arrivée ici et
pourquoi on demande des dessertes à
partir des trains intercités
c'est qu'en ce moment une fois sur deux
vous raté la correspondance à
châteauroux parce que le train du retard
etc
c'est pas pour le plaisir d'en mais
tellement non c'est parce que c'est
invivable
c'est berrichon mbia les chevaux mais il
travaille à paris ont des enfants qui
viennent ici alors pour le voyage ils
préfèrent des trains comme les urbains à
13h15
ils ont fait arrêter celui de paris
austerlitz limoges brive la gaillarde et
ont occupé les voies pendant une dizaine
de minutes
comme pour réhabituer la machine et
toute sa structure à faire escale ici il
faut qu'on puisse faire un aller retour
paris argenton paris ou argenton paris
argenton dans la journée ce qui n'est
absolument pas possible actuellement la
question c'est quel type de cohésion des
territoires en veut est-ce qu'on veut
uniquement développé les grandes
métropoles ou esponde que la vie puisse
continuer dans les territoires ruraux
n'y a pas d'autres questions que celles
là
et puis les habitants ont laissé le
train repartir il était long et bondés
de voyageurs en transhumance vers leur
noël et leur ruralité
ils ont promis qu'il reviendrait un peu
et beaucoup si nécessaire pour
réapprendre locomotive à s'arrêter en
gare d'argenton-sur-creuse